[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public 90
minutes de débats de reportage et
d'analyse comme tous les soirs sur
public Sénac 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
pour notre débat d'actu 100% politique
ce soir on va s'appuyer sur les
résultats de notre baromètre mensuel
avec trois thèmes l'avenir du parti LR à
4 jours de l'élection du nouveau
président la très faible participation
des militants Europe Écologie Les Verts
pour désigner leur nouvelle secrétaire
nationale et puis ce sparadrap McKinsey
qui colle au basket d'Emmanuel Macron
les leçons de novembre sont
passionnantes vous verrez et puis pour
notre débat de société volontairement
décalée de l'actualité du jour on se
pose cette question faut-il inscrire le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution française le ministre de la
Justice y est favorable
et aujourd'hui le droit à l'IVG dans
notre Constitution n'est pas une mesure
gadget un artifice de communication ou
un mouvement de panique face à un
exemple lointain inscrire le droit à
l'IVG cette liberté fondamentale et
inaliénable de la femme c'est une
sécurité pour toutes les femmes de notre
pays
les attaques contre l'IVG sont
nombreuses dans d'autres pays aux
États-Unis en Italie ou en Pologne la
France doit-elle prendre les devants et
protéger ce droit fondamental des femmes
à disposer de leur corps réponse dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord donc
les détails du baromètre au doxa mascara
pour la presse quotidienne régionale et
Public Sénat avec Audrey petaz
j'espère que dans moins d'une semaine
les 91.000 adhérents et l'air voteront
pour se choisir un nouveau chef eux
seuls détiennent la clé du scrutin mais
quand on interroge les sympathisants LR
une base plus large que les votants leur
préférence va à ericsiotiques et d'après
un sondage au doxa il obtient 41%
d'adhésion contre 27 % pour Bruno
retaillod et seulement 17% pour Aurélien
Pradier des candidats qui ont tous pour
projet de réformer le parti mais pour
beaucoup l'avenir de LR ne passerait que
par une alliance 56% des Français 73%
des sympathisants y sont favorables et
quand on leur demande avec quelle partie
la réponse est sans appel LR doit
s'allier à la majorité présidentielle LR
semble avoir perdu de sa superbe ses
anciens chefs aussi l'image de Nicolas
Sarkozy s'effrite même chez les
sympathisants 73% d'entre eux souhaitent
toujours qu'il joue un rôle de
conseiller pour leur partie mais ils
sont moins nombreux 59% à vouloir qu'il
dans la vie politique
et on va continuer de détailler
évidemment les résultats de ce baromètre
avec Gaël Slimane bonsoir Gaëlle Le
président est co-fondateur de doxa avec
Béatrice Giblin bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue géographe directrice de la
revue Hérodote Pascal Perino bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
politologue et professeur à Sciences Po
Paris on est également en duplex avec
Benjamin grandge qui est le président de
mascaret notre Vigi réseaux sociaux pour
ce baromètre on va résumer ça comme ça
bonsoir Benjamin et Laetitia cruppa
éditoris politique est évidemment à mes
côtés comme chaque mardi et chaque jeudi
donc trois grands chapitres je vous le
disais en titre on va commencer par les
LR ensuite on sera autour de du dossier
Europe Écologie Les Verts c'est très
faible participation pour désigner la
nouvelle secrétaire nationale et puis le
dossier McKinsey alors LRS Limans que je
retiens moi en priorité de votre
baromètre on l'a déjà évoqué là avec ce
sujet de d'Audrey beta c'est la volonté
d'alliance des sympathisants LR c'est
quand même assez passionnant c'est assez
passionnant c'est plutôt nouveau en
général les sympathisants alors je
précise ça a été très bien dit dans
votre sujet nous n'interrogeons pas dans
le sondage les militants ceux qui seront
appelés aux urnes ce week-end
une carte qui sont qui représente un
noyau très restreint les sympathisants
se sont tous les gens qui nous disent
qu'ils se sentent proches de ce parti
politique là que c'est le parti
politique dont il se sentent le plus
proche quand on interroge les
sympathisants et même si on interroge
les militants il nous dirait de mon
parti c'est mon parti il a pas à se
dilué à se mélanger surtout dans un
contexte où les autres partis avec une
alliance serait possible sur des parties
actuellement plus forts donc ça veut
dire ça signifierait une dilution du
parti et donc c'est particulièrement
remarquable de voir que quand on demande
aux Français mais surtout aux
sympathisant LR s'il serait favorable à
une alliance avec la majorité
présidentielle d'une part avec leur
rassemblement national d'autre part avec
reconquête pour en troisième lieu et
bien le total de ceux qui disent au
moins oui à une de ces alliances est
majoritaire 73 alors pour les
sympathisants on est à 7 favorable à une
alliance mais ce qui est compliqué c'est
que dans le sujet on disait sans appel
pas tout à fait ça c'est que on ne
parlera d'Éric Ciotti tout à l'heure de
la du tropisme ces dernières années
d'elle à regarder un petit peu plus sur
sa droite toute la difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si vraiment il faut
choisir une alliance celle qui ressort
le plus parmi les trois proposés c'est
davantage une alliance avec la majorité
présidentielle 45% majorité
présidentielle 38% rassemblement
national 31% reconquête et souvent les
deux se recoupent à 38 et 31 on peut
répondre plusieurs réponses possibles
bien sûr donc c'est compliqué parce que
ce qui reste des sympathisants
paradoxalement des sympathisants LR
depuis Zemmour depuis l'émergence d'Éric
Zemmour et l'avènement de son parti
reconquête bah ce sont ceux qui sont
plutôt moins radicaux je parle bien des
sympathisants et pas des militants parce
que ceux qui étaient déjà très radicaux
ils ont trouvé de la radicalité chez
Zemmour et ils sont partis si j'ose dire
chez Éric Zemmour et donc la difficulté
c'est qu'on pourrait se retrouver le
weekend prochain avec peut-être un
erikiothy sur une ligne très à droite on
va dire très conservatrice avec des
militants qui potentiellement peuvent
regarder aussi très à droite mais avec
une base électorale l qui est plutôt
plus sensible aux sirène macronistes
Pascal Perino Sallier sans se dissoudre
c'est une sorte d'équation impossible
quand même pour le parti électron
aujourd'hui surtout quand on représente
électoralement moins de 5 % des
suffrages exprimés quand on est en
position dominée l'alliance forcément
vous n'avez plus qu'un strapontin
premier point deuxième point au fond
c'est sympathisant la couronne la plus
large ils sont beaucoup plus en phase à
mon avis avec les électeurs que ne le
sont les adhérents les militants qui
vont voter parce que quand vous regardez
on vient de sortir un livre sur les
dernières élections présidentielles
législatives et on a analysé
attentivement les électeurs qui avaient
voté Fillon les 20% qui avaient voté
Fillon en 2017 et ces électeurs quand
ils ont quitté LR et bien ils sont
beaucoup plus vers la macronie que vert
Éric Zemmour ou Marine Le Pen c'est à
dire c'est Macron qui a attiré le plus
d'électeurs de droite donc quelque part
ces électeurs c'est sympathisants ils
sont assez cohérents et puis ils sont en
phase avec l'histoire de leur mouvement
l'histoire de LR jadis RP r voilà
UMP etc ça a été une alliance toujours
avec le centre droit c'était la fameuse
alliance rprudf disait-on et c'est comme
ça que ce courant a gagné
même si les rapports ont pu être confiés
etc donc c'est beaucoup plus en phase
avec l'histoire et avec la réalité des
fuites électorales extrêmement
nombreuses que ce courant républicain a
connu dans les mois récents alors
histoire il y a aussi des porosités avec
l'extrême droite depuis le RPR bien sûr
et qui n'ont jamais eu un impact
électoral comme l'a eu de l'Alliance
rprudf ou voilà alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que batterie Gibelin
audience LR majorité présidentielle qui
est donc je rappelle souhaité par 45%
des sympathisants à l'air je redis sont
pas ceux qui vont voter samedi on va y
venir à ceux qui vont voter samedi c'est
un peu ce que propose Nicolas est-ce
qu'on peut proposer Nicolas Sarkozy qui
a été retoqué par d'ailleurs tous les
candidats à la prison petite victoire
pour l'ancien président de la République
comment vous l'analysez ça je tirez pas
petite victoire pour l'ancien président
de la République je pense que c'est pas
sérieux de présenter les choses de cette
façon d'ailleurs le sondage monde qui
n'ont aucune envie qui reviennent
véritablement dans la politique
éventuels mais bon est-ce qu'on n'est
pas on n'est pas désobligeant donc dire
qu'on n'en veut plus du tout c'est ça
serait un délicat donc un rôle de
conseiller pour pourquoi pas mais je
pense pas qu'on puisse parler d'une
petite victoire non c'est simplement
qu'ils sont je crois très pragmatique et
réaliste et que il se trouve que qu'en
plus le j'allais dire le parti du
président il pense quand même plutôt à
droite qu'il ne pense à gauche donc
on n'est pas non plus dans une situation
trop difficile que de suivre au fond on
a un parti de centre droit et dans
lequel on peut parfaitement se retrouver
avec des gens de bonne aloi et ce qui ne
pose pas de problème puis celui-là il a
quand même des chances de gagner donc
c'est quand même aussi un peu
intéressantes
de Laurent Wauquiez puisqu'il dit que
s'il prend la présidence du parti le
candidat en 2027 sera Laurent Wauquiez
qui lui-même se positionne on entend on
commence déjà à l'entendre vous imaginer
et il fait le pari d'une droitisation
constante de l'électorat sur
l'insécurité et sur l'immigration pour
faire un peu rapide sur ces deux de
terrain là maintenant quand on regarde
un peu les sondages sur les
préoccupations des Français les Français
sont pas si à droite que ça et ils ont
aussi des sensibilités qui ne sont pas
aussi radicales ils ont des
préoccupations de justice sociale par
exemple d'égalité de donc je suis pas
sûr que ce soit forcément le bon pari et
comme Marine Le Pen ne sera pas encore
n'ayant pas encore exercé le pouvoir
peut-être qu'on passera ce qui se passe
en Italie c'est-à-dire au fond pourquoi
pas tenter si on va dans la logique
d'une droitisation et d'une
radicalisation
aller aux enjeux de ce week-end à
l'élection du nouveau président du parti
LR et les républicains et là vous avez
évalué les côtes d'adhésion des trois
candidats à la présidence Éric Ciotti en
tête avec 41% de côte d'adhésion Bruno
retaille au 27% au lien Pradier 17%.
mais alors je le répète on l'a déjà dit
une fois dans le sujet vous l'avez dit
une fois je le répète une troisième fois
attention c'est les sympathisants ce
sont pas les 91.000 militants qui
pourront voter samedi malgré tout bon
quelle leçon on peut en tirer alors
d'abord vous avez raison de pointer ces
là vous vous rappelez on le redit tous
les mois notre code d'adhésion sa petite
singularité c'est comprend on passe au
crible une vingtaine ou une trentaine de
personnalités politiques majeures
présentes dans le débat politique et on
demande aux gens si ils ont une forme de
soutien à faire de la sympathie ou de
l'adhésion à leur égard si ils ont ils
ressentent du rejet à leur égard et je
crois qu'on est les seuls à proposer
cette cote de rejet ce qui est pas
toujours très sympathique mais bon c'est
intéressant à savoir ou s'il se sentent
indifférent et premier élément lequel
des trois elle préférait la première des
réponses c'est aucun c'est à dire que le
premier élément à indiquer c'est pas
qu'Eric Ciotti est à 41% de cotes
d'adhésion parce que pardon de cette
lapalissade mais ça veut dire qu'il y a
59% des sympathisants LR qui ne
ressentent absolument aucune forme de
sympathie ou d'adhésion à l'égard d'Éric
Ciotti énorme ces problèmes et c'est le
mieux placé des trois auprès des
sympathisants alors pour les autres
retailler ou Pradier il y a une large
part aussi de méconnaissance ce ne sont
pas des personnalité qui sont encore
extrêmement connus y compris par les
sympathisants et donc on voit que auprès
des sympathisants LR on a une majorité
55% et 57% pour les l'un et l'autre de
sympathisants qui disent j'ai pas d'avis
je sais pas qui c'est et donc c'est de
sympathisants qui de sympathisants qui
ne savent pas qu'il s'agit ou en tout
cas qui ne le connaissent vraiment pas
suffisamment pour donner pour donner un
avis et alors qu'Eric Ciotti a le mérite
le bénéfice d'être un petit peu un petit
peu plus connu donc ça c'est le problème
le deuxième élément c'est ce que vous
soulignez Thomas c'est-à-dire que malgré
tout une fois qu'on a dit ça bah oui en
côte d'adhésion c'est quasiment le
double des autres auprès des
sympathisants ça ne dit rien des
militants sauf que militants et
sympathisant ils sont quand même un peu
pour eux que les militants ils ont de la
famille qui voit bien autour d'eux si on
parle ou pas des champions qu'ils vont
se donner à l'élection donc ça donne
quand même un petit élément plus positif
sur eriksioti sauf que là on rejoint ce
que vous disiez il y a un instant ce
dont on parlait c'est la ligne c'est
admettons qu'il un bénéfice lié à une
plus grande notoriété auprès des
sympathisants et donc des militants le
problème c'est que la ligne qu'il
embrasse qu'il suit qu'il la direction
vers laquelle ils vont emmener le parti
a priori ne correspond pas à ce que nous
demande les sympathisants à ce pourquoi
ils aimeraient voter donc vous allez
vous pourriez vous choisir un homme qui
emmènerait le parti dans une direction
qui n'est pas celle souhaitée j'ajoute
que quand on a testé on le test même
plus là aujourd'hui mais Laurent
Wauquiez pendant des années dans nos
baromètres la ligne qu'il suivait était
vraiment alors on va dire orthogonale
pour être gentil avec les attentes de
l'opinion publique en général et de
l'opinion de droite en particulier et a
priori la stratégie suivie je rejoins ce
que vous disiez c'est si on veut aller
dans de la droitisation Jean-Marie Le
Pen parlait de l'original et de la copie
mais de fait ces dernières années à
chaque fois que la droite classique a
voulu aller vers l'extrême droite ça a
fait monter l'extrême droite ça n'a pas
profité à la droite de gouvernement pas
depuis Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 en tout
cas Pascal peronnot si on rentre un peu
dans la dans la cuisine électorale
est-ce qu'on sait je sais pas si vous
avez
la question des cartes qui a pris sa
carte d'adhérent d'où sont-ils est-ce
qu'ils sont plutôt du Sud-Est cher
erikiotide la Vendée de de Bono
retaillod de Rhône-Alpes la région de
Laurent Wauquiez qui soutient avec ce
titre est-ce qu'on a des infos là-dessus
pour l'instant non on sait cependant que
il y a des mouvements d'adhésion liés à
cette échéance il y a plusieurs milliers
d'adhésion qui sont de nouveaux
adhérents mais qui viennent pourquoi pas
parce que ils ont envie d'adhérer à LR
en ce moment mais parce qu'ils ont envie
de dire leurs mots sur la présidence de
l'air sachant que ça diminuera beaucoup
de choses sur l'avenir de la droite en
France et si on est un électeur de
droite et même de droite modérées on
peut avoir envie de dire son mot et de
choisir l'homme puisqu'il n'y a que des
hommes voilà de choisir l'homme qui
arrivera à maintenir la famille unie
parce qu'on sait le tropisme le goût
presque de cette famille pour des
affrontements d'hommes qui lui ont coûté
très cher dans le passé et là au fond
trois hommes on a qui est Pradier le
moins connu le moins pour l'instant
soutenu par les par les sympathisants
qui est plutôt une droite sociale qu'on
pourrait estimer presque sur la gauche
du dispositifs on a un cioti qui est
toujours sur la ligne qui était
d'ailleurs la sienne il y a un an quand
il était candidat bien sûr à la
candidature
présidentielle qui est une ligne claire
et il a dit même à un moment que pour
lui votez Zemmour éventuellement
pourquoi pas puisque votre clé Macron
et puis on a un retaillot qui est plutôt
sur une position centrale dont on se dit
dans le dispositif c'est lui qui
pourrait peut-être maintenir le mieux
des militants de sensibilité différente
dans une organisation alors que les
autres livraient il faudra suivre
attentivement si le choix des militants
était ericatif faut pas oublier qu'il
est là la tête de la plus grosse
de LR les Alpes-Maritimes mais si c'est
le choix était cieux voilà il faudra
suivre attentivement le nombre de départ
à la suite d'une présidentiotique parce
que il y a déjà des militants qui disent
bon voilà si c'est ce type on ira voir
ailleurs et on voit bien comment horizon
qui est le dispositif droit de la
majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui
attend ce qui pousserait pour horizon de
Bonne Nouvelle Benjamin grange sur les
réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'il y a là il y
a l'un de ces trois candidats LR qui qui
émergent ou est-ce que finalement ça
rejoint ce que disait Gaëlle Slimane
tout à l'heure ils sont un peu pour
certains sous les radars quoi
alors ils sont pas du tout à équivalent
équivalence beaucoup parce que on va
avoir un érikioti qui lui-même a une
notoriété bien supérieure aux autres et
notamment à la suite de la primaire de
la droite je vous rappelle que à cette
époque on avait quand même eu la
surprise de le voir en tête de la
primaire de la droite devant Valérie
Pécresse qu'on donnait
largement favoris et ça a été à la fois
une surprise et en même temps ça a fait
connaître le personnage cioti deuxième
chose quand on regarde les marqueurs en
fait d'Eric Ciotti quand on parle de lui
en fait sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
un marqueur qui le définit et ça
correspond d'ailleurs un peu à ce qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure c'est que
c'est lui qui défend cette ligne
sécuritaire cette ligne beaucoup plus
dure sur sur l'immigration donc si
finalement on essaye de résumer pour les
sympathisants de droite le choix restez
dans un parti de droite
République et finalement aller vers les
sirènes d'ARN qui se normalisent et en
même temps vouloir davantage de ce
marqueur beaucoup plus sécuritaire et
bien un érikiotti c'est presque le
presque le candidat idéal si maintenant
on regarde on regarde les autres ils ont
du mal en fait à émerger c'est-à-dire
qu'on a du mal à associer en fait un
rotéo par exemple avec une mesure fin ou
avec quelque chose qui pourrait dire ça
c'est la personnalité de Roteo merci
Benjamin vous retrouver évidemment tout
à l'heure on a ni les uns ni les autres
parler de des révélations du Canard
Enchaîné concernant erikiotti son épouse
ça émerge pas dans dans l'opinion
peut-être un petit peu peut-être dans
les réseaux sociaux un mot là-dessus
puisque dans l'analyse faite sur les
réseaux par nous dans le sondage on le
repère pas encore mais sur les réseaux
c'est immédiat donc il me semble
pas un grand jeu un mot assez rapide
c'est vrai qu'ericsiotti on en a
beaucoup parlé à cause de l'histoire de
son de son épouse et c'est vrai que ça
tombe un peu ça tombe un peu mal dans la
circonstance parce que lui qui voulait
au contraire essayer de faire passer ses
idées et bien il se trouve que son
volume de conversation augmente presque
de 130 % du fait de cette histoire de
son de son ex et de cumul de cumul de de
d'emploi donc finalement ça vient de
tirer un peu vers le bas alors que c'est
le moment où justement il essaye
d'émerger sur ces marqueurs à molature
je pense que de toute façon elle garde
notoriété est toujours bon à prendre
négatifs c'est toujours de la publicité
c'est toujours de temps ça rappelle
quelques mauvais souvenirs
on a deux autres thèmes à traiter c'est
quand même cette Une du Figaro Magazine
qui n'a pas pu vous vous échapper dans
lequel on voit en portrait alors il y a
que des hommes là aussi
y a-t-il quelqu'un pour sauver la droite
et alors elle a provoqué cette
couverture la rédaction la réaction
pardon de d'Édouard Philippe Lancia
Premier ministre voici ce qui est le
publie sur sur Twitter ici au lieu
d'essayer de sauver la droite on
essayait de servir la France et pas
seulement entre hommes dit-il
il a pas l'air très heureux
Édouard Philippe d'être coincé comme ça
entre Laurent Wauquiez Éric Zemmour
Béatrice gibla qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
inspire cette cette une de nos confrères
de la part du Figaro Magazine
ils sont quand même assez connus pour
leur position extrêmement conservatrice
et très très de droite donc imaginez que
cette fille c'est une femme qui pourrait
sauver la droite c'est au-delà avec
l'échec qui a eu Valérie Pécresse de ce
croire c'est au-delà de ce qu'ils
peuvent imaginer puis à ces quatre
candidats ces trois candidats donc mais
évidemment oui mais il y a on pourrait
pas dans cette sur cette une parce
qu'elle peut Zemmour il y a pas Marine
Le Pen pas Marine Le Pen
de cette couverture mes amours voilà il
faut mettre également Marine Le Pen
puisqu'il y a la solution éventuellement
de sauver la droite par la droite
extrême alors la droite extrême il y a
marine Le Pen et
Eric donc c'est une façon d'en créer
Eric Zemmour dans dans la famille elle
est dans la famille de droite
traditionnel je ne suis ni de droite ni
de gauche donc on peut prendre ce
prétexte j'allais le dire Pascal c'est
que pardon alors Béatrice Gibelin et
juste après il suffit de regarder la
géographie électorale du vote Zemmour la
géographie électorale de votre Zemmour
c'est le 16e arrondissement pour une
part c'est les beaux quartiers de
certains coins cogolais dans le Var où
il a été candidat mais les beaux
quartiers des Alpes-Maritimes pas
n'importe quoi dans le sud-est pas
n'importe quoi les endroits c'est-à-dire
c'est la bourgeoisie qui est chez
Versailles aussi qui s'est permis le
vote pied-noir ça c'est sûr aussi
évidemment dans le cas de Zemmour et qui
se permet de voter à l'extrême droite
parce que Zemmour a été un éditorialiste
du Figaro qu'ils ont lu pendant des
années donc parfaitement fréquentable on
n'a pas vu marine simplement
d'un électorat du Figaro Magazine c'est
unique à Versailles c'était plutôt
Emmanuel Macron mais non
je parle d'une géographie électorale se
dit pas qu'il est arrivé en tête je dis
que là où il fait des voix
insuffisant bien sûr pour lui c'est dans
le lieu de cette bourgeoise
ne se positionnait pas à droite
objectivement la Une du Figaro Magazine
ils ont raison les de ne pas y intégrer
de ne pas y intégrer Marine Le Pen de ne
pas y intégrer alors si on parle des
femmes de ne pas y intégrer Valérie
Pécresse qui est quand même un poids
lourd de la politique à droite parce que
pour le moment en ce moment là le sujet
c'est les trois candidats qui sont trois
hommes et puis vous avez vu sur la photo
il y a quand même si j'ai bien vu il y a
quand même Édouard Philippe c'est pour
ça c'est ce que je disais vous avez un
Édouard Philippe qui est présent c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui le champ des
possibles et c'est la vérité le champ
des possibles pour les lecteurs de
droite il va d'Édouard Philippe donc en
gros d'Emmanuel Macron
à Éric Zemmour qui a bien des égards se
situe bien plus à droite que Marine Le
Pen et c'est effectivement
le moment un choix radical va arriver
sur l'orientation de la droite en France
aussi il faudrait peut-être rajouter
Bruno Le Maire Bruno Le Maire reste
c'est vrai hein dans le peuple de droite
j'allais dire un leader potentiel avéré
bon c'est encore un homme et c'est
encore mais alors ça tombe bien parce
que là il va y avoir que des femmes
puisqu'on va parler deuxième chapitre
dans ce débat 100% politique des du
Congrès Europe Écologie Les Verts pour
désigner donc la future secrétaire
nationale qui doit succéder à Julien
Bayou c'est Marine tondeuillier qui est
conseillère municipal d'Hénin-Beaumont
dans le Pas-de-Calais qui est arrivé en
tête devant 47% des suffrages exprimés
donc voilà au cas de Sophie Bussière qui
était qui est soutenu par Yannick Jadot
et Mélissa Camara ancienne porte-parole
de Sandrine Rousseau à 13 ennemis 47 18
13 et demi donc forte avance pour Marine
tondeleville Laetitia on va analyser
ensemble ces résultats vous y voyez
quand même un rejet à la fois de
Sandrine Rousseau et de Yannick Jannot
est-ce que une nouvelle génération
incarnée par Marine tondeuillier peut
sauver le parti en tous les cas elle
elle y croit il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
d'interviews après ce premier tour de
vote pourquoi parce que franchement ce
congrès Europe Écologie Les Verts est
quasiment passé inaperçu je vous
rappelle qu'il y avait un match de foot
malgré le boycottes de campagne
potentielles avant mais euh
sous les radars voilà on va être honnête
il y a quand même une interview dans le
monde qui est assez intéressante le
lendemain de marine Tondelier qui est
donc arrivé en tête et elle dit la
réalité du parti n'est pas cette
affrontement post primaire entre Jadot
et Rousseau la majorité des adhérents
veut passer à la suite ça tombe bien la
suite c'était le nom c'est le nom de sa
motion et oui elle a opté selon moi pour
la bonne stratégie c'est à dire qu'elle
reconnaît qu'Europe Écologie Les Verts
et pourri depuis des années par des
luttes intestines a rappelez-vous ça va
pas nous rajeunir mais ce duel
fratricide entre Nicolas Hulot et Eva
Joly donc elle le sait c'est bien ce qui
est handicap pour sa famille marine
Tondelier et elle se fixe pourtant des
objectifs très optimistes vous allez
voir c'était une interview sur France 24
la semaine dernière juste avant le vote
quand mon parti les écologistes font
partie de la diversion propose même des
diversions au sujet dont on devrait être
en train de discuter alors on fait
partie du problème je me dis de manière
très cash mais bienveillante parce que
c'est mon parti que j'aime d'amour qui
m'a faite sur un enfant de ce parti mais
en fait il faut que ça change moi je
souhaite je dis c'est un certain défi
mais que d'ici la fin du mandat en soit
un million sympathisants dans ce parti
ça veut dire travailler sur toutes nos
faiblesses les affronter de manière très
lucide ça veut dire aller faire de
l'écologie populaire aller renouer avec
les quartiers populaires avec les
ruralités avec la j'étais ce weekend en
Savoie 20% des Françaises et des
Français habitent en région de montagne
avec des défis inédits à se poser à eux
il faut qu'on soit en mesure de
dialoguer avec toutes ces personnes et
de refonder un nouveau parti d'écologie
avant l'été et d'ici la fin du mandat
d'être un million sympathisant je pense
que l'écologie le vaut bien j'ai vu que
le 1 million vous avez fait tout réagir
les objectifs à des atteints la raison
tant qu'à faire je rappelle juste que
pour le moment le parti compte 11000
adhérents vous voyez il y a une petite
marge marche à franchir mais c'est vrai
vous l'avez dit en lancement Thomas
c'est vrai que ce premier tour
finalement de vote c'est le rejet c'est
le ni ni ni Sandrine Rousseau ni Yannick
Jadot en fait les électeurs ne veulent
ni de du radicalisme
ultra médiatique de l'une et ni de
l'immobilité de l'autre qui on va le
rappeler quand même son score aussi un
piètre score à l'élection présidentielle
4,63% depuis il est quand même quasiment
inaudible il y a une Jadot il nous
annonce dans JDD ce dimanche qu'il crée
un Club un club politique alors si ça
vous intéresse tous première réunion en
ligne c'est ce soir ah si vous voulez
vous faire une idée je vais lui faire de
la pub mais voilà et dans le JDD Yannick
Jadot déclare où sont les radicaux sur
Twitter ou sur le terrain où nous sommes
depuis des décennies j'ai été et je
reste de toutes les luttes je n'ai pas
de leçon à recevoir et au passage bien
sûr il fustige allez hop un petit coup
encore contre son adversaire de la
primaire Sandrine Rousseau il fustige le
populisme écolo alors justement du côté
de Sandrine Rousseau quelle réaction
elle était sur notre antenne hier matin
et alors là on a eu le droit à une
pirouette double piquée de mauvaise foi
je vous laisse juger regardez
l'échec pour moi incroyable de ce
congrès c'est qu'on est passé de 100.000
votants à la primaire à 5300 sur un
congrès comment voulez-vous que
l'écologie devienne un parti qui
marque qui s'impose qui deviennent la
force motrice d'une du Grand
progressiste alors qu'on est 5300
votants et encore avec des procurations
donc ce sont des placés à mon avis 3000
personnes maximum 3000 personnes alors
que c'est l'enjeu majeur du 21e siècle
elle a raison c'est l'enjeu majeur du
XXIe siècle mais alors à aucun moment
elle ne se remet en cause à aucun moment
elle remet en cause toutes les
polémiques qu'elle a lancé et qui reste
encore dans les interviews je veux
vraiment je vous invite tous à regarder
toutes les interviews de n'importe quel
membre écologie on a le mot barbecue qui
va arriver à un moment donné donc elle a
marqué le débat public le sait elle a
plombé son parti et pourtant on va
terminer là-dessus l'écologie voilà
effectivement et partout oui c'est pour
ça qu'elle a raison dans son constat et
c'est vrai que je crois que c'est dans
le top 3 vous allez me dire regarde le
top 3 des préoccupations des Français
elle a jamais eu autant de place dans le
débat public
c'est que ça a été capté par tout le
monde et ils n'en sont plus les
propriétaires et je sais pas si on aura
l'occasion de le dire mais la côte de
popularité quand on teste l'image des
parties la cote de popularité d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts plombes mais avec un
bénéfice initial
un avantage de départ quand on s'appelle
Europe Écologie Les Verts et qu'on est
dans un climat depuis 10-15 ans où les
gens sont très préoccupés par les
questions environnementales ils partent
de très haut mais il descendent en piqué
et il le doivent très largement vous
avez raison à Sandrine Rousseau parce
qu'elle a fait le buzz très
régulièrement médiatiquement mais à
chaque fois ça lui a coûté des points à
elle et à son parti dans l'opinion alors
il y a quand même ce constat de
faiblesse Béatrice Gibelin ce ce 5300
votants effectivement c'est c'est assez
pharaon quoi pour attendez on verra
combien on a de votants samedi aussi de
91000 un peu plus haut donc
peut être aussi surpris quand même
surtout la moyenne d'âge de ceux qui
vont aller voter voilà mais moi je suis
pas très très étonné en fait c'est quand
même un parti dans lequel les querelles
sont majeures vraiment et constante
constante constante et c'est
décourageant pour des militants c'est
des égaux qui passent pas les portes ni
les animaux ni les autres bon très
clairement et Marine tour de lier étant
la plus calme du Lot je serais remarqué
que ces deux candidates qui viennent de
la région du Nord
l'une était en fait la la campagne de
Sandrine Rousseau et l'autre est dans
l'opposition à Hénin-Beaumont et c'est
intéressant parce qu'elles viennent
toutes les deux d'une région dans lequel
écologie Europe Écologie Les Verts ne
font pas des scores majeurs du tout
c'est pas là que les choses sont les
plus les plus importantes et ça m'étonne
qu'elle soit qu'elles émergées toutes
les deux là dedans mais franchement
les querelles très très violentes bon
sans parler de l'affaire Bayou qui en
rajoute encore une couche supplémentaire
dont on entend assez démissionné il a
démissionné effectivement vous avez
raison et puis surtout l'écologie elle
est maintenant prise en charge partout
c'est à dire qu'on ne les attend plus
pour régler les problèmes alors
l'écureuils vous vous disiez ce qui
lasse les militants c'est exactement ce
que ce que dit cette adhérence s'appelle
Antoine Guéno lacets des querelles
médiatisées on l'écoute
moi je pense que on est on est très
faible quand on s'investit par média
interposés on l'a vu sur les bassines on
l'a vu sur d'autres occasions moi je
pense que les écologistes doivent
apprendre à internaliser leurs conflits
à le faire à le faire entre eux et donc
c'est l'enjeu aussi de ce congrès là
c'est de se dire qu'on est capable aussi
de se parler sans se mettre avoir des
modules dans les médias il y a Benjamin
grange qui nous faisait signe pendant
pendant qu'on écoutait ce ce cette
adhérent vous y intervenir sur cette
partie du débat on vous écoute
en fait il y a deux choses quand on
écoute en fait ce que l'on dit de ce de
du parti Europe Écologie Les Verts la
première c'est que ce parti n'a pas
encore acquis le droit d'être un parti
de gouvernement ça reste en fait un
parti d'opposition un parti militant un
parti extrêmement vertical dans les
marqueurs qui essayent de défendre et ça
il est évident que ce serait un
challenge pour pour le le nouveau leader
de ce ou la nouveau leader de ce parti
le deuxième point c'est que dans les
conversations on retrouve et ça c'est
vraiment nouveau depuis deux ans un
clivage terrible entre effectivement
l'aile Jadot qui est une aile on va dire
qui a pas réussi finalement à faire
rentrer l'écologie dans la société au vu
en fait des scores et qui est critiqué
pour ça et puis on va trouver une une
frange extrêmement militante extrêmement
radicale qui est défendu par Sandrine
Rousseau et celle-là elle ne plaît pas
non plus à tous les militants en tout
cas
au sommet du palmarès du rejet elle
parvient à réussit le tour de force à
être au niveau des Éric Zemmour des
Marine Le Pen ou des Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui sont si j'ose dire les gens qu'on
adore le plus détester en France mais
qui ont eux des codes d'adhésion qui ne
sont pas ridicules donc Sandrine
Rousseau soit vous la détestez mais en
tout cas vous n'adhérez pas c'est et la
conséquence sur le parti Europe écologie
des Verts c'est que vous avez un parti
qui était de très loin il y a trois ans
le parti préféré en tout cas celui ça
voulait pas dire que ça se traduisait
dans les votes
on en a une bonne opinion c'est bien et
vous aviez 50% de cotes d'opinion les
autres parties étaient à 35 36 donc 14
points devant tous les autres mais ils
se sont effondré de 14 points et ils
sont aujourd'hui au niveau de
Renaissance au niveau de LR ils sont au
niveau de ces parties là et ça c'est
quand même merci à Sandrine Rousseau et
au débat qu'elle a porté ses 12 derniers
mois un dernier mois ensuite on parle de
de l'affaire MC Pascal Perino on verra
combien de militants LR participent au
vote alors c'est samedi résultat
dimanche c'est sur le sur le week-end
samedi et dimanche il y a quand même un
concept d'affaiblissement de nos partis
politiques quoi c'est non bien sûr ça
devient dramatique parce que en effet
tous ces consultations internes dans les
parties touchent des micro-publiques des
niches de plus en plus minuscules et on
se demande de quoi ces adhérents ils
sont courageux d'être adhérents mais ces
adhérents sont représentatifs qu'est-ce
qu'il représente peuvent-ils encore
parler au nom des électeurs qui vont
attirer dans les élections locales dans
les élections nationales la réponse de
manière évidente et non et donc ça pose
un problème de légitimité de tous les
corps intermédiaires qui peu à peu
s'enfonce et ça renforce la crise de la
politique ou face au pouvoir il y a des
citoyens un peu
déboussolés des individus qui n'ont plus
d'insertion dans des corps
intermédiaires et propose le problème
d'un espace public qui devient un espace
public de l'affrontement direct entre
des citoyens en colère et un pouvoir
exécutif un président et une première
ministre qui ne savent plus où donner de
la tête alors justement on va en parler
de l'exécutif je termine avec cette
enquête ouverte par 3 juges
d'instruction sur la sincérité des
comptes de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 et 2022 investigation du parquet
national financier qui vise les liens
entre le candidat et le cabinet de
conseil McKinsey le présent de la
République qui a réagi c'était vendredi
dernier en marche d'un déplacement en
Côte d'Or
tout ça on en a longuement parlé pendant
la campagne du présidentiel j'avais été
déjà amené à réagir c'est au tour de
tout ce qui s'est dit autour de makinzee
et qui a pu choqué beaucoup d'entre nous
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup aussi de
sujets de
fraude fiscale prétendu etc etc donc moi
je me suis exprimé quand j'étais
candidat sur ce sujet j'ai appris comme
vous par la presse que il y avait des
associations et des élus qui avait
décidé de saisir la justice c'est normal
que la justice fasse son travail elle le
fait librement elle va faire justement
la lumière sur sur ce sujet vous savez
mes comptes de campagne de 2017 ils ont
déjà été soumis à toutes les procédures
au juge ils ont été validés par les
procédures que nos lois prévoient ce
2022 sont en chemin comme tous les
candidats moi je pense c'est une très
bonne chose
et que toute la lumière soit faite et
que la transparence soit faite et
j'accueille tout de suite sur ce plateau
quand un calmé bonsoir Quentin vous
connaissez bien ce dossier vous en avez
tirez un documentaire pour publier sur
le travail des sénateurs justement
dernier rebondissement entre guillemets
de ce feuilleton mais sénateurs qui
veulent changer la loi exactement les
sénateurs de la commission d'enquête sur
les cabinets de conseils vont déposer un
amendement au projet de loi de finance
l'idée est de revenir à la charge pour
plus de transparence dans leur
proposition c'est sénateurs veulent que
le gouvernement publie toutes les
prestations car c'était tout le reproche
de la commission d'enquête cette opacité
autour du travail de ces cabinets de
conseils privés dans la sphère publique
c'était l'un des reproches de la
commission d'enquête lorsqu'elle avait
remis ses conclusions c'était en mars
dernier les sénateurs avaient déjà voté
une proposition de loi qu'elle est dans
ce sens ça avait été adopté à
l'unanimité le 18 octobre dernier mais
cela n'a pas été repris par l'Assemblée
nationale donc ils accélèrent et
profitent du débat budgétaire pour
forcer la main du gouvernement cet
amendement par examiner en séance lundi
ou mardi la semaine prochaine et tout ça
dans ce contexte donc dont je parlais
des nouvelles enquêtes du parquet
national financier voilà on va revoir ce
que effectivement jeudi le parquet
national financier a annoncé via un
communiqué plusieurs procédures sont en
cours en plus de celles sur le
blanchiment de fraude fiscale qui avait
été ouverte contre McKinsey qu'on
entendait connaissance depuis le mois
d'avril dernier la justice enquête sur
donc les conditions d'intervention de
cabinet de conseils dans les campagnes
électorales de 2017 et 2022 également le
communiqué Bloyer ajoute une information
judiciaire est ouverte sur l'échelle de
favoritisme et de Russell le favoritisme
écoutez la réaction au Sénat du
président du groupe socialiste Patrick
Kanner
je suis très heureux finalement que la
commission d'enquête que nous avons
initié et je salue le travail de
notamment de ma collègue Eliane assassy
qui a été à l'initiative de cette
mission d'enquête aboutissent
aujourd'hui à ce que finalement on
commence à regarder ce qui se passe
entre les relations entre les pouvoirs
publics et ses cabinets de conseils qui
doivent pas être les cabinets obscurs
l'enquête fera son travail naturellement
moi je n'ai pas à commenter une décision
de justice qui est en cours
potentiellement mais voilà la
clarification doit intervenir je suis
heureux que ce soit le Sénat qui
finalement par son travail avec un vote
à l'unanimité et bien a pu permettre ce
déclenchement voilà les sénateurs qui ne
commandent pas davantage dans la
décision de justice et ils veulent quand
même revenir dans un communiqué ils sont
revenus les deux sénateurs de la
commission d'enquête sur les principales
voilà les informations de leur rapport
ils avaient bien montré un les dépenses
en hausse ce milliard sur la seule année
2021 et aussi le fait que la Commission
avait mis au jour que mckinson avait pas
payé d'impôts alors justement
c'était l'une des auditions phares de
cette commission d'enquête et elle avait
effectivement travaillé la commission
d'enquête sur les liens entre en marche
et McKinsey écoutez un extrait du
reportage effectivement de public c'est
là où on voit ce lien écoute un extrait
une vingtaine de salariés de votre
société au réparticipé donc à cette à
cette campagne comment avez-vous assuré
les règles liées au conflit d'intérêt
comme vous le savez la loi française est
extrêmement protectrice des libertés
individuelles de chacun à pouvoir
participer à des activités politiques
associatives ou collectif et donc moi en
tant qu'employeur je ne suis pas
habilité ne serait-ce qu'à demander à
une personne si elle exerce des
activités ou l'implication politique
pour nous-mêmes membres de la commission
d'enquête c'est problématique parce que
nous pouvons craindre s'il y a eu ce
genre d'engagement bénévoles de salariés
en nombre quand même d'une entreprise de
conseils privés dans une campagne
électorale il y est un risque à un
moment quelconque de d'ascenseur voilà
des retours d'ascenseur c'est la
question à laquelle devra donc répondre
le parquet national financier mais dans
le rapport sénatorial que on a
re-regardé cet après-midi on lique
McKinsey accumulé beaucoup de missions
pendant la crise sanitaire montant total
12 millions d'euros c'est deux fois plus
que le deuxième cabinet de conseils
sollicité pendant cette crise sanitaire
merci Quentin calmer pour toutes ces
informations Pascal Perrineau moi qui
suis tintinophile j'emploie l'expression
le sparadrap c'est le c'est le sparadrap
d'Emmanuel Macron ce dossier oui c'est
le sparadra d'Emmanuel Macron mais ça
dépasse la présidence Macron parce que
au fond le recours à ces groupes privés
correspond à un affaiblissement de
l'appareil de l'État de multiples
missions jadis était remplie par
l'appareil de l'État l'appareil de
l'État avait suffisamment de compétences
en interne pour
accomplir ses missions aujourd'hui à
partir d'un diagnostic est-ce que le
diagnostic est avéré d'affaiblissement
de l'État on va chercher les compétences
en dehors et bien sûr peuvent se nouer à
ce moment-là des rapports des renvois
d'ascenseur qu'on vient de le dire et
puis peut-être un coût parfois
excessivement élevé des missions
accomplies par ces groupes de conseils
coût qui n'est pas du tout équivalent
quand on a recours j'allais dire au
secteur public au fonctionnel ou à
l'appareil de l'État ça n'a rien à voir
et parfois il y a encore tout de même de
l'expertise dans le secteur public dans
l'appareil de l'État et peut-être un
recours un peu facile excessif à ces
groupes de conseils d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'a dit le ministre de l'économie et
des finances on fait entendre sa
boutique musique il a fait entendre sa
petite musique particulière mais le
jugement du ministre de l'économie et
des finances je crois est marqué au coin
d'une certaine vérité
Slimane si on regarde la côte d'adhésion
du président de la République d'Emmanuel
Macron on est à 38% c'est ça c'est un
peu son son etiage le plus bas
on est quand même enfin évidemment c'est
une réélection mais enfin l'élection
présidentielle n'a pas eu lieu il y a un
siècle il y a plus d'oxygène quand on
est à 38% de côtes de popularité il y a
déjà eu bien pire ça pourrait être bien
plus dramatique mais on est pas si loin
de ça réélection de son élection c'est
faible les effets de ce dont nous
parlons les rebonds plus exactement de
ce de cette polémique ne se font
probablement pas en concentir dans notre
mesure et nous n'en sommes nous ne
sommes pas encore dans le dur des
réformes complexes qui pourraient être
annoncées et susciter une très grande
colère sociale je pense notamment à la
réforme des retraites avec l'idée du
report de l'âge légal qui rend les gens
fous de rage donc très majoritairement
hostile depuis très longtemps il le
disent il l'exprime ils expliquent que
si ça se concrétise ils iront se
mobiliser ils iront manifester
la conjonction des ennuis la Chirac
pardonnez-moi un disait les merdes ça
vole en escadrille là
je m'emmerde vous avez raison les gens
merde ça vole en escadrille là on est un
petit peu dans ce schéma là pour pour
Emmanuel Macron Béatrice Gibel la
au-delà de du dossier McKinsey peut-être
plus sur la côte d'adhésion est-ce que
vous vous comprenez ce ressenti des
Français sur fondaflation sur pour
autant l'inflation en France est quand
même l'une des plus faibles d'Europe si
je me trompe pas non je dois dire que je
suis ça m'interroge un peu de voir cette
cette mauvaise humeur constante les
Français sont en colère cette expression
être en colère
me mettrai en colère d'une certaine
façon dans la mesure où quand même en
pendant la pandémie qu'on vient de vivre
s'il y a bien un peuple des citoyens qui
ont été accompagnés protégés plus que
partout ailleurs c'est c'est quand même
là quand vous voyez comment les les gens
de la culture hurle sur le fait que non
c'est scandaleux qu'on les laisse tomber
quand vous voyez comment la France a le
gouvernement français a soutenu tout le
champ culturel pendant la pandémie moi
honnêtement ça me ça m'interroge un peu
et puis un autre terme qui revient assez
radicalité voilà on se radicalise alors
elle est fils radicalise tout le monde
est dans un discours de radicalité
et je me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent en fait au delà de ça vous
regardez la situation géopolitique
internationale il y a de quoi vraiment
ça y est franchement et de prendre et je
lui dis mais quel nombre est enfin
on est on est vraiment dans une
situation extrêmement grave vraiment
qu'on n'a pas connu depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale les choses
peuvent vraiment mal tourner il faut
quand même être conscient en conscient
de ça et et on est là à dire on est en
colère c'est scandaleux je veux dire
tout le monde en Europe et même meilleur
travail beaucoup plus que nos 62 ou 63
ans mais non pas question enfin moi je
m'interroge il y a une tradition
française d'être pas content et j'avais
écrit il y a très longtemps un papier
les enfants gâtés de la République et
ben je le pense encore mais il y a
certainement une responsabilité des
politiques aussi dans ce désamour
c'était pas le moment de poser cette
question parce que le débat est terminé
mais une constatation merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat bientôt sur sur Public Sénat à
sans doute dans un mois pour est-ce
qu'on sera bon sur le baromètre
mi-décembre on va essayer on va essayer
de le sortir ça tombe bien parce qu'on
compte sur vous merci beaucoup Gaëlle
merci Benjamin grand évidemment
également en du